the lions meanwhile are the ones who
have jared goth there's been speculation
about whether or not they'd be
interested in taking a quarterback at
number seven brad holmes the new gm of
the team says that the recent trades
that have happened with
the 49ers moving to three
the dolphins ending up at six with the
eagles dropping out
holmes says that it doesn't change their
draft plans at all so the lions should
be targeting what or whom with that
seventh overall pick well i look at it
two different ways i mean you know you
know enough about the lions here let me
just throw these out there what do you
think i mean first off we saw barbin
jones and kenny gallaudet leave a wide
receiver so that would be one position
i'd look at and go wait you want jared
goff to work and you want to be able to
sell that
you know will will devonte smith or
jamar chase be there at seven there's a
good chance
okay mike so there's that avenue i look
at and then the other thing i just look
at is going
you know
a defensive lineman
a difference maker up there you know i
haven't watched linebackers yet as far
as stand-up linebackers so i don't know
where those guys stand quite yet i can't
give you that money but pass rushers
there's one or two or three guys that
are worthy of being right there in that
pic and and again when we talk about the
lions there's just there's no difference
maker up front on the front seven so to
me it's one of those two areas and pass
rusher or a wide receiver and i don't
know mike when you look at the lines
what do you what do you think is more
desperate there well absolutely receiver
yeah when you have those those two best
receivers on your team leave but i have
flashbacks to charles rogers and roy
williams sure and mike williams now
calvin johnson worked out well from
macmillan and company but this is the
team that seemed like it was drafting a
receiver in the first round every year
and we talked earlier about the bengals
being in prime position to call the
broncos or
who else uh is in that in that carolina
pantheon talk about the panthers or the
broncos about trading up
you could give the lions a call about
getting in front of the dolphins if
that's where the dolphins are looking
and and you get potent you get your
choice of receivers if it goes
quarterback quarterback quarterback
quarterback
and you aren't looking quarterback is
the lions you move up with the bengals
you got the first pick in the draft yeah
so i don't know what it would take to
move up two spots but that's something
to consider as well to cut the line in
front of the dolphins if there's a
receiver that they really love if it is
devante smith if it is jamar chase and
they don't want the dolphins to get that
guy cut the line get your guy and then
you've got someone jared goff can throw
to
i still don't rule out a quarterback for
them although i think it becomes less
and less likely yeah as these teams are
stacking up in front of them that are
going to be taking quarterbacks yeah no
i mean agreed and i think the other
thing you could talk about with the wide
receiver thing too is just like
you know again does it matter does does
jared goff the kind of guy that needs
that like home run throw the ball 50
yards down the field type of threat i
think that's a real question i'm not
sure he's necessarily that type of
quarterback anyways you know so that and
you know more than likely or listen i i
know i've studied to study the receivers
there'll be a good one there in the top
of the second round too to think that
maybe you could go that direction so
yeah i'll be interested to see what they
go as far as that's concerned you know
they try to get a weapon for anthony
lynn's offense there and stretch the
field a little bit or do they help aaron
glenn and the defense a little bit and
get a top you know a top flight pass
rusher or something like that they got
position needs everywhere i mean the
lions are a rebuild of a football team
there's nothing you look at on their
team where you go
well
they're good in that department i mean
really no they need a little work just
about everywhere on their roster and
they got a lot a lot of work in front of
them
yeah i and and i i think the fact that
they swap stafford for golf and part of
that deal was they were inheriting the
rams horrible contract and paying off 40
some million fully guaranteed over the
next couple of years getting those two
first round picks getting that third
round pick this is about building
something and and you know it it's a
strange dichotomy because you go from
having bob quinn as the gm and matt
patricia is the head coach and there's
this sense of we're pushing we're
pushing we're pushing to win win win win
win and then you hit the reset button
and it's kind of like okay we're taking
a huge step back
and
this is going to be a while folks you're
used to it we've been crap for 60 years
haven't won a playoff game for 30. give
us a year or two to figure out exactly
where in the hell we are because other
than looking for guys who bite kneecaps
we're not quite sure what we're looking
for or what we have by way of players
well yeah you're right i mean they could
be in you know just the the best player
available type scenario i mean
it could be an offensive lineman you
know again like i said i don't know
about the linebackers there they could
be a team that just goes to look to
trade down and go you know we need a lot
of stuff there's not one guy here in the
top ten you know it'll be interesting
just to see what they do there as far as
they got a lot of ways to go there's a
lot of building to go on the football
team and there's not you know i'm
excited about the running back with
swift and tj hawkinson at tight end you
know and again okwara had a pretty good
year as a pass rush of the year this
year he showed up they're paying all
that money to trey flowers we haven't
seen him show up so i don't know maybe
they don't go the pass rusher that i
talked about there maybe they ride that
out another year maybe it is more about
defensive tackle
linebacker safety something like that um
but either way i know the lions team is
is in a little bit of a rebuild mode
and i think all the draft picks they use
this year are going to be used on guys
that fit that mold i i joke about
kneecap biting i mean dan campbell is
the one who said it but it's that old
school throwback that 49ers mentality of
we don't need to practice tackling we
can roll out of bed and put you on your
ass that's the mindset they're looking
for that's the chris spielman mindset
sure rick spielman told me a few weeks
ago after his wife saw the dan campbell
introductory press conference rick
spielman's wife said
this is exactly the guy chris is going
to hire to be his head coach right so
that's the other side of it here there's
there's a lot of spoons in the stew in
detroit you've got campbell as the head
coach brad holmes is a gm chris spielman
who has a lot of juice in that
organization now is basically the
surrogate for owner sheila fordham rod
wood the ceo of the team who's got a lot
of juice more than the usual ceo who who
stays out of football
so he doesn't get fired when it goes
sideways they're going to have i think
a challenge
reaching a consensus because spielman
and campbell are going to be pushing for
that guy that they got excited about
because they saw the film where he put
some guy on his ass yeah i i mean yeah
yeah i i don't disagree with that you
know you also think hey campbell you
know he comes from the the bill parcells
sean payton's school of thought you know
anthony lynn are rough and tough you
know wants to run the ball be physical
type of guy i mean that's where you get
into the offensive line conversation
there's going to be some guys there too
but maybe that's where dan campbell
looks at it goes well i want to set it
up like sean payton did with the saints
we're going to have a great offensive
line to start with dominate you up there
and then they're gonna work on it i i
can see it go to all
all angles here certainly but i think
you're right it's going there's a lot of
cooks in the kitchen but i do think
they're all roughnecks there for lack of
a better way to say it and they're going
to try to get that guy that kind of fits
that new attitude of the detroit lion
football team
absolutely absolutely and i think once
they make that pick i have a feeling
we're going to say yep we should have
made sense right that one coming
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports